ses avocats réclament à parler de ton
truc car il s'en va pas parler que
d'octogone ce soir non non ça c'était
une invention
on va en parler tous les deux
merci je crois que sur la tête je suis
pote avec booba moi je sais que ton
meilleur ami ou bien ouais c'est vrai on
s'autorise père bien tu vois ça leur
parle quand même d'un mec je vais en
vacances
berthod c'est fini les vacances pour toi
c'est oui je sais alors franchement sexy
alors cette émission on en parle après
de l'accord on en parle après moi je
veux dire en plus tu es déjà venu ici
aussi été hyper bien passé entre nous on
s'est toujours bien entendu aussi tous
les deux et c'est vrai que voilà tu sais
j'ai été dire tu peux qui fait nadal et
qui fait federer non mais voilà tu veux
mais monsieur aubin regarde à moi d'en
bouffer entre nadal et federer
voilà mes mots quand même pas rien en
tout cas je te le dis voilà où des noirs
garde ce serait aussi ses tenues qui
donneront leur réponse
qu'est ce que tu veux faire de ma vie
tout est venu c'est sûr qu'ils regardent
mais nombre arrête et franchement à
arrêter là c'est comme ça je vais partir
j'allais partir takan écraser l'ail
ce qui t'arrive tu es sorti honnête et
je te le dis l'album est vraiment très
réussie en noir 3 et ça c'est
l'essentiel
je le dis non c'est vrai bravo parce que
c'est d'abord avant de avant de
s'embrouiller tu t'es d'abord un mec qui
fait de la musique
et franchement le son et tous les sons
sont très très bons donc bravo à toi tu
es l'essentiel ce soir et on va parler
tous les deux après on va parler avec
les téléspectateurs avec tout le monde
mais pour l'instant voilà on va faire un
voir ce que vous avez fait de ces
dernières 24 heures comme tous les jours
qu à risquer sa fais toi
tout à fait en fait lâché en promo donc
c'est un peu compliqué effet me wade et
que tu trouves du times qui fait qu on
progresse de plus de punitions la
nouvelle saison ah ouais ouais un acteur
depuis ni sur celui que dans morandini
potable mais bien regarder les lots 6 à
9 de son pote nature à regarder
l'épisode 6 et battu à un moment il ya
[Rires]
boubacar bah si vous regardez une
apparition arrêtez avec ça et le jaune
va m'arrêter car elle est allée jolie
christine kelly un super loto
j'adore comme sakho c'est une belle
femme intelligente à la soupe orange
elle à tout prix n'a rien laissé pourrir
un film l'excellent gilet jaune mais je
me prépare pour demain
vous avez beaucoup d'humour
[Rires]
comme ça on va montrer ses toiles moi
qui se passe cyril c'est son
anniversaire mercredi pour josh est
d'ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
et vous vous avez un petit creux
pourquoi il est bon ancien membre du csa
je me tais alors on s'en foutait ploce
ça non mais attends dans ma tante et
dans toi mon pote tu peux dire que tu
kiffes charisme qu'il n'ya pas de mal il
est très beau garçon
alors voilà j'ai beaucoup de qualités
mais l'aboutissement des fous alors
alors alors c'est je te défends je dis
pas je te défends de parler comme ça tu
me lis tes de mieux en mieux et je ne
colle pas à couper un peu la barre un
peu ça te va beaucoup mieux c'est vrai
que je suis un dj ce monsieur là tu as
pris un peu plus tu tu as fini sur la
vente était plus comme ça tâter plus
comme ça regardez c'est vrai
là
hu
ils malaquais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors je voudrais vous dire que pendant
le magnéto incident m'a dit qu'elle qui
fait bien car ici ou pas oui mais tu
peux le dire mais y'a pas de mal tant il
allait il est très joli rapporte rien
mais j'aime bien car et si j'aime bien
son corps j'aime bien son visage bien
s'amuser j'aime pas les parents voilà
mais je parle à mes sont foulés par
olive
je me sentais pas dire je vais déjà ravi
juste pour toi comment tu plusieurs
habits pour toi s'il est plus prononcée
sur ce gros avec toi ici aller et
mathieu alors voilà maintenant
mais dans ce super bien bon mathieu
dansera côté jean-rené en boîtiers tap a
annoncé alors tu danseras mais tu restes
un peu comme ça tu vois je regarde non
non excusez moi c'était depuis 1er route
2018 les relations entre booba et carris
ne cesse de faire parler donc après un
combat voilà après ce qui s'est passé
donc à l'aéroport d'orly en août dernier
il ya eu une idée qui a germé d'un
combat entre vous deux
on a fait un petit récapitulatif et vous
allez nous en parler après car ils ont
parlé tous les deux et on va dire au
monde ce qu'il en est regardez c'est
parti s'il n'avait pas mis le nez sur
instagram durant les vacances vous êtes
peut-être passer à côté de ce qui
pourrait être le combat du siècle
la nouvelle idée de booba depuis noël
organisé un combat avec caris pourront
terré l'âge d'or une nouvelle étape dans
la guerre qui oppose les rappeur booba
et carris souvenez vous c'est déjà eu
qui avait créé le buzz cet été en se
battant à l'aéroport d'orly une bagarre
générale qui avait fini par
l'interpellation des deux hommes est une
condamnation à 18 mois de prison avec
sursis et 50000 euros damende depuis
boubakary continue de se lancer des
piques sur les réseaux sociaux
une tradition qui a fini par agacer
booba qui le jour de noël a décidé de
passer d'instagram à la réalité
en proposant à caris de l'affronter sur
un ring au coeur une invitation à
laquelle le rappeur a répondu non sans
provocation je te propose un octogone
sans arbitre sans règles je te brise les
os le dopage sera interdit bien
évidemment et vient pas à 12,7 fois le
combat qui devrait avoir lieu en avril
est en cours de préparation après
plusieurs échanges interposés sur les
réseaux sociaux entre booba et carris
ses charismes qui a officialisé la
nouvelle il ya quelques jours dans la
presse le rappeur de sevran a expliqué
qu'il était prêt à aller jusqu'au bout
et à se battre avec booba dans un match
de boxe avec à la clé un montant pouvant
aller jusqu'à un million d'euros
alors qu'harry c'est avec nous carisse
alors on veut savoir où on en est ou de
cette affaire déjà tu vas nous expliquer
de 12 dire puisque apparemment était
alors déjà fait cette histoire là
lorsque comme c'est ton pote je dois
savoir alors oui c'est vrai que c'est
mon pote voit là j'avoue que j'aime
beaucoup
voilà mais il ya eu cette histoire il
quitte à lancer un défi
non non arabes ont dénoncé le d'études
doit bien l'histoire commence à
commencer moi je pense courant marqué
l'histoire à l'histoire du combat
maintenant que nous en avons discuté
tout ça alors non non non pas du tout il
a dénoncé un devil il avait dit voilà
moi j'aimerais bien faire un combat
contre toi voilà contre toi en boxe
anglaise s'est malheureusement non
si le 25 du matin il a dit j'ai organisé
un combat avec cyril a alors eu l'idée
en fait c'était moi j'ai bien au courant
monter parce que avant et avait et avait
lancé un défi jamais descendue dans les
si jamais c'est pas sortie de nulle part
après honda
j'ai appris ça on s'est parlé tous les
deux et voilà on s'est dit tiens on
pourra organiser pourquoi je te dis
franchement nous moi je sais pas
d'incitation à la violence
et moi j'ai qu'une envie c'est parce que
voilà je peux me j'adore booba lui et
droit doit franchement [ __ ] il faut
aussi merci c'est gentil et moi j'ai
juste envie de vous réconcilier ces je
suis le rabibochage tard non mais c'est
vrai que je suis de rabibochage est ce
qu'il ya une chance pour quand vous
réconcilier ou pas alors que c'est la
première phrase la première prise de
parole de booba en tribunes sincérité la
hache de guerre est enterrée avec harris
d'accord donc ça ça te fait plaisir
non seulement fait plaisir vraiment tu
devrais te poser la question sur le fait
de dire on va enterrer la hache de
guerre
mais justement lui il a dit cela il ya
un problème en fait ouais mais lui a dit
tu as des manteaux les x entend
justement lui l'année qui voulaient
enterrer la hache de guerre autour d'un
combat à la sécheresse a dit à la juge
le combat là je le dirai tempérer ce
qu'il a dit oui mais trois mois après il
dit pour enterrer la hache de guerre
pour faire un combat combat combat de
boxe
pourquoi parce que et on en a parlé tous
les deux mais on empêche de dire en
faisant croire non mais si alors que
j'ai des 8 me dit il me dit c'est vrai
que la boxe salle une valeur de caudry
lui annonça des belles valeurs
je ne sais pas un boxeur comment il peut
avoir des valeurs de combat m non mais
c'est vrai que ça et là dans la boxe moi
je voi hd font là les valeurs de la boxe
et et vous le savez ici et c'est vrai
que voilà je me suis dit au lieu qu'ils
se tapent devant tout le monde dans un
aéroport ou quand ils vont se croiser ou
que ça fasse encore des mecs qui vont
être qu'ils vont être choqués des
on est avec des enfants à côté tout ça
peut-être c'est mieux d'organiser un
truc voilà un combat de boxe
moi je pense que c'est une blague boxe
anglaise parce que sinon ça va être
n'importe quoi avec des vraies règles
un vrai arbitre ou bien vous organiser
un truc sur un ring et vous faites juste
un petit bisou et vous repartez chacun
de votre côté et donc selon toi qu'on va
se battre sur le revenu après l'âge de
glace rente et non mais alors pas été
raisonnable sinon vous non mais sinon
vous battez pas du tout et c'est donc ce
comme c'est ton ami de montluc est ce
qu'il veut toi tu as envie de te
réconcilier avec la paire moi j'ai pas
besoin d'aidé a déjà des animaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors alors voilà alors on y va
je m'appelais donc booba pouvait rester
on a peut être avoir besoin d'autres
avocats les plus bas on rappelle la
faire vous n'êtes plus les meilleurs
amis du monde vous étiez copains moment
les deux ou par jamais été son coach ait
jamais connu d'accord merci en tout cas
c'est clair
vous êtes sûr que je l'appelle alors je
vais l'appeler d'accord et calme toi je
te jure ce entendu cela fait un peu de
moi je rigole pas et donc tu veux tu
veux que tu veux quoi tu veux qu'on
essaie de vous rabibocher où vous voulez
quoi discuter
écoute je crois que c'est un truc tu
attends pas compris à booba c'est ton
pote c'est vrai et tu le sais ce qu'ils
pensent au fond de lui puisque c'est ton
pote non il n'y a pas d'histoire de
rabibochage introduit moi je sais bien
donc c'est un peu ma vie de mon côté lui
fait sa vie de son côté se sont jetés
varie de mon côté mais pas content c'est
buback et sur moi c'est pas moi donc si
tu veux la paix à peine et je vais lui
dire direct à gramat personnes qui
flippe ici a pas de l'appel que tu vois
là on est très amis côté chanson halo
halo halo
comment ça va tu m'entends ça va alors
on est sur le plateau en direct comment
ça va peut être en forme
merci mon chéri de sa lutte et pme et
merci impôts lui dire merci on peut là
pour dire merci
alors y'a qu'à risque est là et carris
ça varie de 10 à dakar il fera bon quoi
et ça démarre très bien alors booba tu
as dit que tu voulais en tirer mais dont
on tue frérot on se calme
s'il vous plaît on n'est pas venu pour
ça on fera tout le séminaire met à mal à
bas et sans lever la balle à l'intérieur
booba booba bombe a dit qu'il voulait
enterrer la hache de guerre
elle n'a pas d'ancrage de attendait deux
minutes parce que lui et vous l'enterrez
la hache de guerre est alors pris en
otage de guerre même si un contrat même
si un combat sera pas enterré nous c'est
très bien alors d'autres
alors il nous avons tous vu que je t'ai
dit elle entend pas laisser le répondre
booba bon alors appareil arrive est
inquiète apparemment je te dis ou
baccharis ne veut pas combattre voilà il
faut dix ans non mais moi je le dis je
suis chaud comme jamais oui mais oui
mais non mais on veut pas de bas il faut
pas se battre c'est lui qui a inventé
cette histoire scénarisée ne faut pas
soit nous on aime bien l'idée d'accords
téléphone on rigole 15 heures on a bien
rigolé comme un nombre un sérieux pas
dans la rue n'en veut plus de combats
dans la rue par jour à cause directement
dans la rue allent à orly c'est lui qui
a commencé
c'est lui qui est venu avec ses potes
non mais juste non mais oui mais
justement on ne veut plus de ça même
booba il faut plus de ça alors il veut
plus a donc il veut se battre sur un
ring demi tonne et un truc chez les 10
ans des souris fois je crois que c'était
une mauvaise idée
attend ces contrats il m'arrivait
t'inquiète pas de lui qui s'inquiète par
booba booba juste voilà yakari ce cas on
se calme voilà juste toi on répète parce
que je monte et il a des murs jamais
j'appellerai surtout à tout non
maintenant mais là il a nommé il avala
il ay la politique c'est toi qu'un
pourrir deux minutes le cari la parole
de mieux parce qu'en plus on l'entend il
est au téléphone insultes sans fois j'ai
appliqué secondes sur ton un stade quoi
tu parles de politesse à baisser après
mon but est avec toi on se calme pas mal
et pas moi 2000 et open stress à mes
parents alors je te le dis voilà lui
booba ils voulaient enterrer la hache de
guerre il faut aller plus battre dans la
rue comme ça il a dû enfin vrai combat
de boxe
voilà relégué avec cet os bon alors je
vais devoir toi aussi
alors je sors je pense que pour
l'instant le rabibochage entre vous
boubakeur
pour l'instant le combat cariste ou non
mais ce que voulait faire ce combat mois
les promoteurs qui est venu voir
ouais tu m'as parlé d'un million d'euros
ok maintenant les trucs qu'il a mis
dedans il ya des choses qui n'allaient
pas donc je lui ai renvoyé et là il a
renvoyé à mon avocat et 36 on est en
train de les revoir tout ce qu'il veut
au contraire
moi ce que je t'ai pas foule de coquelin
kg ars oi jamais où on n'entend pas bien
bon bah donc vous bâti nous un truc pas
envie de l'entendre s'y attendait leur
laissez le parler ça c'est aussi honteux
alors on y va
bon bah on t'écoute et après ce sera
après des années sera le mot de la fin
parce qu'on doit rendre l'antenne
d'accord donc et octogone concrets comme
défonce dès ce jour là mon poème est ce
que vous est ce que vous croyez vraiment
que c'est la meilleure solution
lui pense que c'est la meilleure
solution mais solution pourquoi pour
bape au bassin pourquoi enterrer la
hache de guerre s'est tenue à la
question non mais bon tu as
bon écoute et en tout cas je ne sais pas
d'où cette affaire non mais ce combat
nous ce qu'on veut c'est un combat dans
les règles avec les règles de boxe mine
de rien la valeur de la boxe et mai car
aig cédera bourse au mois d'octobre elle
alors il dit moi c'est un artiste
maintenant s'il veut se battre contre
moi ça va être un combat de rue c'est ce
que je voudrais lui dire dramane ça
voilà donc qui apparemment il n'y aura
pas de combat de monde lui mon pote chez
moi je suis déçu quand la salle ont bavé
comme une caméra quand et à la salle et
avait des maquilleuses tout sa grand
mère tu fais du cinéma ont ralenti dans
la salle de sport ce qu'il a dit il y
avait pas grand mère
[Musique]
je veux répondre à ça tombe on n'a
jamais eu l'habitude voir comme ça j'ai
carole rousseau derrière la raison
d'insultés des grands mères c'est
vraiment quelqu'un d'intelligent
mais est ce que oui il était là c'est ça
la question je me pose est ce qu il
prenant le bret qui tu sais tu es là
c'est trop booba booba tout à jouer de
faire la grève du jour je voulais faire
un gros bisou au thème
elle m'a dit je cherche toi et on met ça
suffit ça suffit on la boîte vous bac es
parti voilà est non mais ça va pas toi
ensuite mon chrono
une façon de parler l'expression
calme-toi bon écoutez en tout cas je
leur ami